- Welcome back to Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and I'm the technical director
for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the third lesson of the series. In the first two lessons, we talked about the basics
of quantum information.
First for single systems in isolation and then for multiple systems.
We also discussed standard
basis measurements and unitary operations in both the single and
multiple system settings.
In this lesson, we'll introduce
the quantum circuit model, which gives us a standard way to describe quantum computations,
and we can also use quantum circuits to describe quantum protocols and other sorts of interactions involving multiple quantum devices.
In addition to quantum circuits, we'll also discuss some
important mathematical concepts connected with quantum information,
and we'll use them to observe
a few fundamental limitations on quantum information and what we can do with quantum circuits.
That'll set us up well for
the lesson following this one where we'll see a few
very important examples and that will conclude the
first unit of the series
on the basics of quantum information.
Here's an overview of the lesson. We'll start with the quantum circuit model and we'll see how it works.
Then we'll talk about the
critically important notion of an inner product, as well as orthonormality and projections,
which are connected with inner products. We didn't discuss these things
in the first two lessons, because we really didn't
need to, but now we do.
Inner products provide us
with a mathematical tool that we simply could not do without.
We just would not get far in understanding quantum information and
computation without inner products.
And in the third part of the lesson, we'll take a look at a
few important limitations of quantum information.
Ultimately, what we want to do is to explore interesting
things that we can do with quantum information, but in order to do this effectively,
we need to be aware of some
things that we can't do.
In particular, we'll discuss
the notion of a global phase and why global phases are irrelevant.
We'll see a statement of
the no-cloning theorem, which tells us that quantum states can't be copied in general, and we'll see that two quantum states
can't be perfectly
discriminated from one another unless they're orthogonal, which is a fundamental
limitation to be aware of.
The first topic for the lesson
is the quantum circuit model, which is a model of computation
that provides us with a way
to describe quantum computations.
The quantum circuit model is
based on a more general notion in computer science of a circuit, and you can define many
different models of computation
based on this general notion.
The basic idea is that a
circuit is composed of wires which carry information, and gates, which represent operations
that are applied to the
information carried by the wires.
The term circuit is actually
kind of a strange name to use for this sort of a model
because the word circuit
usually refers to a
circular path of some sort.
But when we talk about circuits
as models of computation, we're usually talking
about acyclic circuits
where circular paths are not allowed.
To be more precise, for the
purposes of this series, we're going to demand that
information always flows from left to right in any circuit.
So if you prefer, you
can think about circuits as describing sequences of operations where time goes from left to right.
Here's an example of a Boolean circuit where the wires carry binary
values, either zero or one,
and the gates represent
Boolean logic operations.
The wires are represented by lines, and here we have two input
bits labeled X and Y,
and if we want to know
what the circuit does on a particular choice of inputs, we propagate the values on
the wires from left to right,
depending on the actions
that the gates have on the values that are
carried by the wires.
So for instance, we can
take a look at what happens when we start out with the top input wire set to the value one and the bottom input wire
set to the value zero.
These two input wires lead
into these two dots right here, which represent fan-out operations, which means that the value is copied
so that it can be carried
forward along multiple wires.
So if we do this, then these
two wires take the value one, which is the same as this one, and these two wires take the value zero,
which is the same as this one.
Here we have a NOT gate which
is indicated by the symbol for logical negation, so the
value that comes out is a zero,
which is the logical negation of one. And similarly, the value
that comes out of this gate is a one which is the
logical negation of zero.
These two gates are AND gates,
this gate is an OR gate, and if we continue on
and propagate the values